[Music]
for some life is good but in dangerous
times things can change in a heartbeat
as Warfare gets more sophisticated the
capacity for human error increases our
world is moving faster and becoming too
complex for the human brain alone to
process we need help introducing tldr
threat likelihood deadline
recommendation the world's most advanced
artificial intelligence defense system
powering you to make critical decisions
faster than ever before
tldr
helping you make the world a safer place
[Music]
foreign
that's why today we are pleased to
announce
tldr
threat likelihood deadline
recommendation a command and control
system that helps you make sense of
global sensor data
both Military and Commercial at machine
speeds
so this thing is basically Skynet from
those movies where everyone died
no
I've always said if you take the human
choices out of the process entirely it
will end in disaster I'm talking about
informing human choices not replacing
them
with the very best data on all the key
decisions so it won't act autonomously
humans will always control the AI
not the other way around
get it tested get it deployed I want it
watching the skies watching cyberspace
watching China get the Allies goodbye in
we need to be first on this
foreign
[Music]
there it is again
multiple attacks now sir
something's probing Us by the Taiwan
link from Taiwan seem to be Chinese in
origin the Chinese wouldn't hack our
nuclear control
serious
[Music]
oh
yeah
looks like they're serious sir first
cyber attacks and now second is
reporting Communications between some of
their nuclear facilities
so this is escalating and it's happening
fast
well we know what they're doing
we don't know is why
the president's on his way how long is
he going to be the speed this is going
we may have to go to Defcon 3.
it's too late for that sir
wasn't the system meant to give us more
time to make decisions
[Music]
signals are going out to Chinese
unmanned submarines Mr President we
can't be certain but we believe they may
be kill orders
[Music]
foreign
by fake data from the other side
so much for the humans will always be in
control of the AI
now getting word from the Chinese to
stand down they're saying they're as
confused as we are but that could all be
part of the script
[Music]
nuclear missile Subs
200 nuclear warheads and some of our
finest onboard
it's hard to say if they started it or
if we started it
download
[Music]
either way
we have to assume it's starting Mr
President we need to move to the bunker
now
[Music]
crying day
not tonight
the world is out there for you
don't go crying babe
[Music]
it's just the sound of changing
the darkness comes alive
from the darkness comes the light from
the darkness comes the light
[Music]